Dave Clark works for the Cincinnati
Enquirer and kind enough to join us
after these articles man things must be
slow day in Cincinnati if I'm the
headline maker there Dave well you know
this is this was going for me
I love exaggeration the more
exaggeration the better the story is
going to do well yeah I mean do you find
when you know when you're hearing the
words come out of your mouth like the
Bengals defense is terrible and I don't
know if that Taylor is a head coach I
mean this is any part of you think
you're going a little bit too far do you
think the Bengals defense is great no no
but I don't know about terrible okay I
yeah okay I do you are you sold on on
Shaq Taylor's your head coach do you
know what you have there no I don't
think okay that's all I said
I don't know and I don't think the
defense is any good thanks so that's all
so why I don't know why you brought up
those two things because I those aren't
controversial those but that that's sort
of based in fact you don't know what you
have in your head coach and your defense
isn't very good didn't any good but yeah
I don't know if he's a head coach and
the defense is terrible I mean it just
seems a little bit harsh and it's like
kind of but it's the kind of thing that
I live for you know but David I'm not
invested in the Bengals you're you're a
local you write for the since I inquire
I'm I grew up there I'm not invested in
the Bengals my job is to assess the
Bengals the way I would the San
Francisco 49ers I said I don't know if
they they know what they have with Jimmy
Garoppolo yet is that harsh yeah
Kyle Shanahan can he make the right
calls when he needs to
I mean that's all I got it I got a weird
vibe from Joe burrow that's all it would
just felt non-committal I hope he goes
to the Bengals Dave I hope that that
they he has great success and they get a
chance to play in a Super Bowl again and
win and Cincinnati could certainly use
our player I just got a weird vibe there
and then I wondered if he really wanted
to go there and then if you said as I
just talked to Todd McShea hey who's in
a Cincinnati guy hey Todd would you
rather go to the Bengals or the Dolphins
if you're Joe burrow then he said the
Dolphins so we're on the outside looking
in you're on the inside and that's where
it's different my opinion is just my
assessment of this situation it could be
Jacksonville it could be Carolina it's
just because I'm from Cincinnati people
think why are you saying mean things
about the Bengals I'm just saying what I
think it's my opinion that's all there's
no it's it's not based in hatred or you
know anything I get it but I write about
really anything anyone says about
Cincinnati sports our teams anyone who
grew up here but plays professionally
elsewhere that sort of thing so hearing
the remarks you made are kind of right
in my wheelhouse and you know any the
more exaggeration the better you know
when you say guys who probably passed on
McVeigh in an airport and therefore you
get a job that's a joke well I know but
I hear that and I'm like oh yes I'm
transcribing this this is going to do
well well you could put in parentheses
meant as humor because that's what it
was how many to everybody joked about
anybody who knew Sean McVeigh you
somehow got a job and I think I think
most people completely understand that
that's a joke but you know you're always
going to get people who read that and
get fired up if they're you know I hope
they continue to sort i hope all these
bengal fans go out and support the
bengals this year I hope it's pal - yeah
I hope it spins back there can I go back
for Thanksgiving that's what I want to
know do I have to go do I have to go to
Cuyahoga Falls instead of Mason Ohio I
the funny thing is I saw it once at the
B dubs in bayson yeah and it was it was
that Thanksgiving
yeah I was with probably my two brothers
and we were we were having beers well
I've been there a couple of times but
that's my tradition I go to Buffalo Wild
Wings
I try to ignore everybody else in the
family I just go with to my brother's to
have beers there and talk badly about
everybody in our family it's a tradition
unlike any other day and I I wasn't
gonna bug you but I said to my friend I
look there's Dan Patrick you from here
you know you and I decide what's the
article going to be like tomorrow about
this conversation yeah yes is this is
this gonna be an essential and inquire
around the website I don't think so
that's right that might seem a little
self-serving on my part
hey join join the club it feels like I'm
being self-serving here with some angle
I'm being served up by Vig by bangle
fans and that's another thing I don't
want anybody to think this is about
Bengals fans this is about the Bengals
themselves and how many of these people
who have responded went to the Superbowl
in Detroit when they lost went to the
Super Bowl in Miami when they lost has
been around this team from the start of
it I I saw Bruce cause let play I saw
Sam Weiss play I went to Nippert Stadium
I saw Paul Robinson play so it's not
that I'm foreign to this topic I'm a
little traumatized by all of this with
the Bengals that's all people should
feel sorry for me like oh my God look
what happened to Dan Patrick he used to
be a respected journalist oh my god yes
that's what happened Dave well I don't I
don't I feel like I should apologize
it's you could do that in column form
just to say you know what that poor guy
is traumatized he went through the icky
shuffle but you know when the highs and
he I covered Collinsworth as a rookie
Dave I've been around this this I wore
tiger stripes Bengal stripes I did all
of this come on it's bringing up bad
memories Dave that's all
can we write the headline for Dave
tomorrow if he does choose to write a
column Pauly do you have one
[ __ ] hairdos bat tracks on an angle
bashing it flows perfectly okay if you
want to do that one Patrick welcome back
to Ohio for Thanksgiving question mark
yes Todd borrow the hatchet things are
okay okay okay all right
did you read into any of that that Joe
Burrell had to say Dave when he was on
with me yeah I don't I mean does it even
matter no I'm just curious they're gonna
take him you know what I figure is
they're gonna take him I know but did
you write anything into that song that's
all I was saying I hope they take him
it felt non-committal that's all yeah
felt non-committal that's it
yeah I could see that next time I come
in to Mason and you see me Dave come on
up and I'll buy you a beer okay the
wings are on me thanks Pam and thanks
for it
thanks for being a good sport and I'll
let you know if I get around to bashing
the Bengals again thanks for having me
on the show it's Dave Clark cincinnati
enquirer for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]